I have good news for you today in that a
bad person lost their job but it's still
all wrapped in terrible news which is
that Fox News is still combining with
the Trump administration to continue
spreading violent disinformation about
the virus I'm talking now about former
Fox News host trish regan really a phial
person trish regan was until recently a
Fox Business Channel host she went on
one of the most unhinged Trump defending
coronavirus minimizing rants that we've
ever seen just a couple of weeks ago and
Fox has said bye-bye to her although we
don't yet know exactly why check out the
first part of this bizarre rant
everything about it is wacky and
deranged this was again a couple of
weeks ago when we knew this was a crisis
take a look we've reached a tipping
point the chorus of hate being leveled
at the president is nearing a crescendo
as Democrats blame him and only him for
a virus that originated halfway around
the world this is yet another attempt to
impeach the president and sadly it seems
they care very little for any of the
destruction they are leaving in their
wake losses in the stock market all this
unfortunately just part of the political
casualties for them you know this is the
time to be united not to be pointing
fingers not to be encouraging hate and
yet what do we see we see the absolute
opposite from the left tonight good
evening everyone i am trish regan the
heat is boiling over many in the liberal
media using and i mean using coronavirus
in an attempt to demonize and destroy
the president this monologue which
should really be Exhibit A and media
literacy classes for distinguishing
between news and opinion identifying
bias identifying unstable people maybe
in a psychology class
it went on for five minutes and really
it peaked at the end when Trish Regan
couldn't even keep her nonsense straight
off of the teleprompter sort of got lost
in her own teleprompter while continuing
to in a completely unhinged fact freeway
defend Donald Trump and minimized the
virus here's the wrap-up
to her lunatic soliloquy for the media
to spin a narrative that this sell-off
and this virus are all a result of
President Trump it's just wrong
but unfortunately I guess they needed
someone to blame they were looking for
someone to blame they want to blame him
for literally anything they can and they
have no real interest shall we say in
finding who's to blame who is the root
cause of all this from what we can tell
this all originated out of China
you know when Donald Trump is their
political target that's all they need
and that's tonight's Intel so the good
news is by by trish regan the bad news
is Fox is still a disaster it's also not
clear that this rant is why she was
fired it may be it may not be Fox has
only been saying you know we thank Trish
and we wish her continued success so we
don't even really know the full reality
of it one idea is that trish regan may
sort of be like the sacrificial lamb for
all of fox news because you've got the
Fox and Friends clowns in the morning
talking about flying around and going to
restaurants and wanting to get their
nails done you have sean hannity talking
about how vaping might protect you from
coronavirus and suggesting unproven
prophylactic treatments for the virus
according to reporter gabriel sherman
fox news is actually worried about
possible legal liability for their
coronavirus downplaying so maybe they're
tossing trish regan out of there to say
hey listen we took it seriously we
pulled her off the air we cut ties with
her we did the right thing while
allowing everybody else to continue
spouting the nonsense
so that's trish regan we do have one
more foxnews related story today which
is about that lunatic right wing judge
Jeanine Pirro who appeared visibly drunk
during her weekend program also
presumably being produced from her home
at this point so let's talk about that
one next
have you ever wanted to learn to play
the guitar but you've had trouble
committing to the time and money
required to actually take lessons I have
the perfect solution for you it's called
fender play it's an app developed by the
iconic guitar company fender it lets you
learn to play your favorite songs in
minutes on your schedule with
interactive video lessons that are very
easy to follow you can use it for guitar
bass or ukulele I've been using fender
play to learn the ukulele I've gotten a
lot better than I thought I would in a
couple of months I had tried teaching
myself using some YouTube videos didn't
really get anywhere night and day
difference since I've started using
fender play and they have personalized
learning paths that will cater to your
musical tastes you can use it on your
phone tablet or computer and you learn
at your own pace which is just awesome
one year of membership gives you access
to thousands of lessons for less than
the cost of one traditional in-person
lesson and when you go to fender dot-com
slash Pakman you'll get to try it
totally free for two whole weeks free
two week trial don't lose out on that
without any commitment that's f en de
are calm slash Pakman PA que ma n fender
dot-com slash Pakman